ça va paraître étrange, j'ai
traversé
le temps, tu viens de disparaître, je ne peux pas continuer à
le regarder parce que c'est horrible, c'est
à nous de sauver cet endroit, tu as
environ une
heure, tu as environ 5 minutes, tu  tu ferais
mieux de
courir Loki, allez absolument
pas Loki saison 2 en streaming le 5 octobre
sur Disney Plus, c'est parti, le
premier jour, je suis ravi d'être de
retour à
TVA, tout passe à la vitesse supérieure, les
enjeux sont énormes, allez voir Tom dans un
costume et  beaucoup de gens vont aimer
que nous ayons introduit ce tout nouveau coin
du MCU et ces nouveaux
personnages. Je suis fan de l'
univers Marvel depuis longtemps, je suis très reconnaissant
de faire partie de cette incroyable série,
rassurez-vous.  notre Loki sera avec notre Mobius
et ils feront face aux
conséquences de cette première saison dans
l'obscurité, tu ne penses pas que je pensais que c'était
parfait dans la saison 2, c'est à propos de Loki se
comprenant lui-même Loki a toujours
été un méchant ce que nous voulons  explorer,
c'est aussi Loki découvrir à quoi ressemble vraiment l'héroïsme
nous jouons à Dieu nous sommes des dieux il a
trouvé une nouvelle famille il y a une nouvelle
capacité à établir des liens
qu'est-ce que tu veux vraiment je veux
sauver mes amis il se rend compte que
ces connexions sont toutes  peu importe à
la
fin, l'incroyable Loki, tout le monde, il sera
là toute la
semaine [Applaudissements] [Musique]